So why are we focused on a designer, an engineer, and a storyteller?
Well, we think these roles serve as a great entry point for
learning about and creating data visualizations.
Some of you may be coming from design backgrounds with a portfolio of projects,
while others of you may have more coding experience and
can port to software, GitHub, or other websites you've engineered.
And still others may be familiar with writing journals and/or communication.
Whatever your background, we hope to teach you something new in this class and
we hope that you get to share your experiences and
your expertise with our udacious learning community.
Now I'm going to hand it off to Jonathan,
who's going to cover data visualization in the context of data science.